first of all whoa obviously how's your
tuberculosis is that coming together
yeah I don't know what that meant dude
how you doing I feel like haven't seen
you in a while buddy you know wha Pal I
miss you you really sure you like me
look a little bit tired around the eyes
what's going on I look tired well as
little sit I was in Portland you got a
little cold you Paulie
mmm I started like a little chest cold
and then I think I was just the proud
boys were in Portland I was a little
stressed who are the proud boys are
those the not all right the neo-nazis
right you're not gonna like that
listen some of them are very nice bring
it up some of them are very nice people
I'm sure it was weird seeing it man I'm
talking I was in the hole I think that
picture yeah were they Nazis were they
were they problem I was very so the
proud boys is a far-right neo-fascist
organization it's only men as members
and promotes political violence is based
in the United States and those friends
can Australia all over yes and I see
them you dude they were in costumes and
[ __ ] it was crazy in in Nazi costumes no
like real shitty Halloween costumes dude
that was on Rogen's show that he got
yeah
and then auntie pho was there right he
was on Rogen show yeah hold up before
he's a proud boy he's on Rogen's cuz he
used to work for advice it's not like
Rome oh I remember that guy who's on
money supporting Trump enough yeah then
lost his job he's from Canada I don't
know but he's a vice guy well he was a
vice dionyza head of proud boys but it
was interesting to see cos and Tifa and
them going at it right it was just low
energy white people just argue it's like
what are you guys yeah well it's
Portland I was like what do you guys
deal with its Portland there's a lot of
uh apparently Oregon and the area of
around Portland as liberal as this has
got a shitload radio Nazi a lottery so
yeah do I tell you what though I was
with Chappelle Lacey and uh and Derek
posted to African Americans right yeah
during that rally oh that's cool but we
we got done on Thursday night and we
went got the Mexican food like the only
place that was open and is Quito cuz I
could eat Quito there so we go in there
right and Derek goes to the bathroom
he's gone for like 25 minutes
I think it's about God their get thicker
[ __ ]
like making fun he comes back and goes
there's a strip club right by in the
bathroom we go the [ __ ] you talking
about you there's a strip club in the
bathroom I go there's strip goes dude do
you know where to get to the bathroom on
the right is a strip club and the waiter
goes oh it's the oldest strip club in
America man yeah it's a tiny little one
we just it's hitting back there
we go back there and it's like probably
the size of this room and just a little
small sliver there and then just this
Portland dime really oh she was hot none
after that I got a little dice cuz cuz
Portland dime can mean and I wanted to
talk to the la-5
curvy very white with a lot of tattoos I
have a lack all of them white and
technical yeah yeah and then the
piercing one of them was smoke show and
then this one I had some ones I told
Derek I said I call this chumming the
water yeah I put the ones out on the
table and just Chum though I said here
comes big red because there's this
Vickie redhead Vicki I say here comes
big red yeah a lot of those girls have
they spent some time at voodoo donuts
and that's finals yeah and there's not a
lot of fake tits they're just they
dubbed their mama they're they're soft
ik women they're they're little
there's race club there it is Wow that's
it right there bro Mary's Club dine and
dance yeah that look at that it's the
old strip club man wow there's something
really kind of sexy about all of this
well I was balls deep in my [ __ ]
chicken bowl right and then the guys I
can bring your food back damn like well
that's one thing I don't make food in
strippers dude I mean I'm is up there
and then it gets progressively go over
yeah light rum the waters which on the
water yeah
and some groupers came out you know I'm
saying hey guys sometimes what happens
is the groupers live because they're not
all gonna be made tend to be rockfish
and not come out they're not gonna
behave goes yeah we got some flounders
yeah we got some flounder huh couple
yields came by a couple of morays couple
more a couple more a couple groups
couple group grew because the groupers
only see the Sun when when there's
something very tasty at the very top no
rule bottled up and they go way back
down to the dark and then there's a
bunch of sperm whales in there for catch
my drift
Oh sperm lot of dudes oh I thought
you're talking about the kind of
large women who like sperm I call those
sperm whales Ono saying I don't know
they say the sperm of the whale okay but
that's how it looks dude that's a hell
of a pole I hope that's up to regulation
brass Paul here's what there's one lady
who got up there look like my aunt I was
like what the [ __ ] you who told you can
make money doing this yeah it's
impressive
you know a little factory of Portland
you know have more strip clubs per
capita than anywhere else in the world
nice I think that's true no I'm telling
you I think it might also be it might
harken back to the fact that it was a
logging town so they were poor is there
a lot of pools like without just just
like with Alaska men alone they come
they want to dance they want a [ __ ] no
one looking to [ __ ] looking at girl you
know looking for women that's the same
thing that's going on now in the pipe
we're in North Dakota blazing in North
Dakota all the strippers are headed up
there man okay flocked up there those
autumn ends of the winter it's right
they flock to where the [ __ ] and
money's that do they flock to the [ __ ]
they flock to the [ __ ] [ __ ] Fox we call
himcall thought [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] Fox for most girls oh that's a coat
it was weird man with those proud ways
being in town like I was telling
cheering like it's like the purge was
happening downtown was shut down
businesses were shut down
damn you could escape boarded down the
middle of the freeway oh shut off
bridges what
and then cops were great the cops that a
lot of kid might show on Friday and I
came in where you staying I told him
like you're in the thick of it so do
your show go back your room don't hang
out tomorrow oh it really is just trust
me don't hang out and there's the proud
boys there's the proud boys let me see
those guys with all day all lift there
were in some big boys that that dude
looks like he's wearing a I don't know
our vest yeah yeah he's very happy with
his mom really wasn't too much violence
the cop with him he's like you know it's
just an Tifa and proud boys they like
[ __ ] with each other yes like but
nothing people got maced and like
there's a few people got hit but nothing
like crazy last year I think four people
died but this year they were ready to go
it's a little scary because this is a
show Brian the picture unpolarized I'd
be I was scared
I was like I'm just not comfortable with
it I just well you can psyche I want to
get coffee and then I hear like get back
into your hotel or to your house get on
streets
okay to you and so ah this is me getting
coffee I see them like oh [ __ ] there's
all the proud boys all the SWAT team
coming cuz it that's all you hear yeah
and then I'm like I gotta check it out
can I see the cops and they're standing
there like they make a wall so you can't
get through yeah and they're standing
there and then I see the one left the
mask Oh Brent job like what's up dawg
and he gets that line he takes he's like
what's up bro he's like man then they
also come around like dude protect them
protect the [ __ ] people man like Alva
in the foot guy was funny just they're
not gonna do [ __ ] they would already
done it yeah I go yeah but they rap at
5:00 right from 12:00 to 5:00 he goes oh
they don't have a hard out sir it's not
like five hits are like guard boy let's
wrap it up rapido flashes they don't
have a hard out you didn't see any Nazi
flags you just saw American flags though
right
uh there are neo-fascist that's
different a neo-nazi yeah I don't know
even order anytime you hear somebody's a
neo-fascist you believe in a hierarchy
or they don't even I'm pretty sure they
don't believe in they don't want
government they want to close up the
borders and women should be in the
kitchen and okay what's guild so I agree
with you it's probably my flashes my
problem is a post-world War two ideology
that includes significant elements of
fascism neo factionism includes
ultra-nationalism so America first
racial supremacy oh boy okay guys okay
great populism for the people
authoritarianism yes which is order you
know there's there's usually one leader
and everybody if they don't like
government but they believe in what's a
military's assumption yeah and then the
xenophobia go to proud boy in Wikipedia
shows what they believe in now some of
it I'm all checked I can't I can't I
can't I'm joking yeah I don't know dude
you sound your eyes look super sentido
excuse that my show I went what are you
doing here brother
that's pretty well your big Trump
supporter leaves you important
interesting
now he said he was there for a UH no go
to the Cowboys for right
neo-fascist learning that members up men
only he-man woman haters Club Western
values the group sees man especially
white men as under siege white genocide
conspiracy like okay keep going keep
scrolling down chin
do you see anywhere how you get in do I
need to sign some again McGinnis found
advice magazine did do they charge a fee
keeps going down there was a list of
like rules membership membership four
stages I'm a proud Western okay well
yeah it's interesting man but as you can
see in that picture go back to that
picture chin top so I go I'm getting
coffee here come now your well here it
is
I just got a peep around then I get
attacked me even though I look white I'm
a Mexican don't you attack me like that
yeah I took a picture oh look I know
exactly who you are
UFC guy like you people in the UFC what
are you talking about
I was at that famous fighting news now
you are you one of the biggest people in
MMA period and everybody who likes MMA
knows who you are interesting and then
you walk in there and you're bigger and
stronger there they all know who the
[ __ ] you are
they you I they probably recruit me
you're a proud boy you're a proud boy
they have I'm proud and I'm a boy if
that's what you mean now well I'm also
saying that you should take a look at
their ideology they don't believe in
masturbation or watching pornography
they want you to get off the couch and
get out there and [ __ ] you know that in
this one really yeah okay dude all right
get out there hey I'm right a hard time
not agree with you an American
I love me okay well that's you deja -
hey man are you all I'm saying is that
you make fun of Asians a lot so you you
and the whites do I employee Asians you
like white girls some of them would you
say you love white girls I love all
girls would you say you love white if
you loved white girls before well I have
before yes and you have friends who are
white that you love yeah but I love
white well but think about white people
right here Brian tell me hey I'm Dan
name someone who employs more minorities
than me
no I know whole staff is Asian openers
on the road I have an Indian a black
dude and then a purple dude yeah now
you're not at Chappelle's black black he
certainly is
you're basically Schindler I'm Schindler
of comedy yeah yeah you know she pal
lacy was um a d1 college cheerleader yes
cheerleader you know [ __ ] right a very
athletic very very acrobatic he's not
though lady basketball with him he's and
I hate me for this he's the worst
basketball player ever he might be a but
I think you can do flips and crazy [ __ ]
with his body oh he used to he's a
little thick now you know um I was
talking to Luke Rockhold yesterday about
Daniel Cormier and when Daniel was like
first starting I was like five nine to
60 or something he could just do a
standing backflip with no problem
they're like oh do you see the Freak
Chappelle kills it though man
great guy she's such a great guy great
guy we had as such you know the funnest
time we had was uh in the green room
after Saturday night's shows we got done
we they gave us a bottle of whiskey and
some weed and we listened to music and I
was like I posted videos on my Instagram
story uh yeah I we were having a clay
bomb what a great oh my god hey I'm fun
what a great time that is there's so
much fun so good that you're bringing
those people with you you know you need
people especially we have so much fun
yeah we have so much fun always finds
Chris Chappell and I'm sure he still cuz
we both met Chappell and stand-up live
in Phoenix four years ago remember that
mm-hm and so whenever either one was new
comedy in Phoenix we'd always have Mon
and then he says well the reason I left
is what I met you guys find the kid and
Brad was like dude you got to get out of
here you got to get tell a Saudis itoi's
la yeah I knew he's gonna be successful
yeah Kate you're asked out and so now
he's killing right yeah fresh faces jfl
taught me central post is that like he's
I just loved in my eyes I mean you can't
help but love yeah
now my way about he will tell you cheer
leads every 30 seconds but we'll work on
that but he goes we're all we're sitting
around with will to the manager from
Portland who's the best who's our age
and he played basketball and Derek
played football and called small
divisions like nine college Derek Derek
small division like
in college anyways so we're all around
the table and Chappelle goes we're
talking about something as though I ran
a 4310 die don't hear it don't comment I
keep eating my food wait who said that
Chappelle Lacey okay and he goes you're
not around a43 in college all right they
saw everyone's talking about Chappelle I
have to do this since I've met you said
that interning for about four years now
you gotta quit saying that he goes I
swear to God around 14 I went trust me
you did not run it for three he goes
dude we can ask my high school friends
right now it hear me out here I actually
believe that you think you're an afford
three X's your buddy's timing it showed
you for three yes look at me at 16 or 15
I will have you around for 80 I went 14
I went you probably ran more like a 5-1
he goes no and then Derek goes you want
to see what a 4-3 looks like so we
brought up this year's combine you know
like 1% of all NFL players can run a for
me it was like it's insane it's Randy
Randy Moss I think broke it I think it
was about Sanders it's literally I
there's some guys one hand no one runs
before it's on especially at 16 or 15
and I went anyway you want to keep doing
Chicago's dude I'm telling around for
three I went dude who same ball training
for three you know that he ran for three
he just he just he didn't warm up here
at fourth day I went I'm trust me in
high school you don't run for three and
I said I ran with kid named Wes Felix
his sister and the Olympics last round a
4/5 in high school and it was like top
of this world like you know so but
there's this funny Derek there it
Chappell's like do I'm telling around
forth there all right dude and Derek
goes I'm gonna bring up this year's 43
if you guys ship a luctarius oh my god
you ran that in high school yes I don't
run a fourth day that I go I said I've
got away with all I said I've like let
you get away with it for four years I
said but I believe you're out of four 3s
I didn't run a fourth day I definitely
read a fourth day I go I want your tax
all your friends right here right a
fourth day you bring up a guy right here
I'm just gonna post it on my screen
story he goes hey just found out from
Brent job I don't hunt a four-three a
favor so now the rest of the trip we
called mr. four three
he's awesome look at this first one here
you go
Wow back here at the NFL Scouting
Combine there's Troy Appetit getting us
started with two safeties she's
Laurentian my personal a white guy
that's a white guy running a 4-3 wait a
minute that's a proud boy running a 4-3
gun right it was a track guy 315 Hey
look best of all time four three two
as I said Chappelle with your short
skinny little legs should tell me you
had a 4-3 his legs aren't skinny he's
pretty thick even more soda yeah yeah
exactly correct yes short thick leg
right exactly short that you're not
built for the 4-3 no I mean that's
that's nothing gave me more satisfaction
when you've realized here at afford
three though oh we showed us oh wow no I
didn't run that night it's cool fastest
cornerback a comment among the Texas he
Texas friends though I says good God
good God doesn't look like he's made for
running at all look at his ass and legs
it's so please please expansion blunt
hard on ya that's is better than
Chappell seeing that though yeah like
have you not like this you guys I mean
oh yeah have you been doing any
sprinting work now you're looking there
then yeah you're looking you if you're
not gonna win you're not gonna make on
down 16 pounds 16 16 so now you weigh
155 yep 255
yep okay so when he more play that last
that last 20 it's gonna be a
[ __ ] my able to help you out
what do you got yeah like a steam room
okay
no slim fast no slim slow where is your
where your problem areas my dick takes
up most of my weight okay
we know that where's the other problem
area zero you were the most
uncomfortable with my ass of a fat ass
mm-hmm like pH fat when you took your
shirt off when you
you have to see I know you were a little
self-conscious you talking about my
teeth right yeah wonky had a little but
not crazy about your paunch Parliament I
really wanted use that word never use
for lunch Punk know you've never used
the word pawn no okay I just feel like
not only can you say that dude
alright so but let's just say you have a
paunch step okay a little tum tum tum
tum tum to eat them right okay so how's
your insurance I'll have it at two
thirty five thirty chest anything else
on something I'll have it at two three
hardest thing to lose I have a little
something for you given to me sent to me
sent to you sent to me and mail probably
illegal in a black K through it anavar I
got a anavar of them I got a month's
worth of anavar and it's the real reason
why it does of my you need take a longer
a month right there on the end of our
burns belly fat now I'm not gonna take
it but why don't you want to take my you
don't get rid of that nut sac underneath
your chin what you like the throat
scrotum you don't wanna get rid of that
I'm sorry I'm sorry you get same punch
I've been insecure about that for the
past month yeah I know you have this is
do I have that now I mean I mean your
throat looks like my grandma's Oh
oh my god but back to do you thing you
want do you want to inject an apartheid
not talking about anything else yeah
has this been like in your head for a
while I had I had it ready to go fun of
me make my wheels up what I do now yeah
my wheels off getting that kitchen bro
begin though I keep my chin down now
yeah I know you think it was like this
really your name had daddy knows what's
up bro
name too long dog chin bring up plastic
surgery I want my lids done them on my
little [ __ ]
throws cobbler time how [ __ ] dare
what dude you look like a toad I'm
insecure now I'm not insecure about much
but now I can take care about that
because everyone looks at your throat
that is amazing dude that could be you
[Laughter]
that's you on the Left that's me on the
right Road oh my god man you got that
yet that frog do you got the Frog bro
who we call it oh my god okay just looks
like you got a flush turtleneck ah I'll
get that look that's a big difference
dude that's like date I mean different
woman on the right but whatever oh that
that's a good one it could be you bro
that's impressive back to me though
what's up with this anavar son and how
do we know it's trust worth it's
trustworthy
I guess positive real dude who's really
real trained but I need long it's not
long in a month if I'm gonna look like
[ __ ] we're gonna start with a hog and
I'm gonna do you a solid I'm gonna call
a couple of my friends who work with pro
athletes and do this stuff I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get exactly what you need to
do really
typical typical I only cycle any last
term in four to six weeks
well sure as well run it I think that's
a steroid turn run it I'm gonna Ray hey
ask me what I'm doing you're gonna have
a cycle Scott I'm doing dude
that's what I'm doing what you doing
running some gear what does that mean
you know you're there well I don't
understand letting some gear bro oh
you're running gear running gear in
other words you doing some anavar it is
it pillar injection
uh it's pill have you ever done anything
kind of a steroid ever ever nothing
never done like could afford it when I
was fighting would have definitely done
if I could of together the top everybody
when you were fighting everybody was
doing it I know that's the secret would
you say 95% of the people at yak in the
day now it's all different
yeah Anna was one of the most expensive
anabolic steroids in the market 60
tablets can cost up to $150
I'll take 10 come on baby hey let me ask
you this ten weeks do you think I had a
gun to your head this is gonna put you
in some hot water if I had a gun to your
head do you think that Costa and
ul I'm not answering okay I understand
why you're not it's not fair to you I
think they're running I think they're
running games somebody said these guys
are running gear would you go to the
head is it gonna have somebody can't see
it right Brennan those guys are running
gear go would you go I would I would gun
to the head
I've got my gun to your head and it I
dude if you're wrong we're gonna kill
you I'd say yes you would say yes and
how is it that they get away with it I
mean that's they they are just paula
koklos them it looked way better than
your room air he was Baker
he looked healthy he looked phenomenal
day 28 28 I mean twenty-five to forty
two-year-old you all's phenomenal a lot
of people I have you well winning that
fight I didn't you didn't I mean you can
give either way III don't know how
they're doing I don't know but you're
saying gun to the head
I am I always assumed guys are on it but
I don't Kosta was caught twice with that
IV thing so mm-hmm car with the IV thing
yeah look man I don't think it might be
the best body I think's I mean it's uh
he is a handsome dope all you names the
eraser what he doing dude
just call yourself the best-looking guy
in the world no dude Carlo the BOD coach
yeah Paulo the best-looking guy in the
world Costa what's the problem odd no
that's the BOD look at that [ __ ] I'm the
BOD I'm not I guarantee you all beat
them in the dick game though I heard he
just got the Cuban missle down I'm sure
he does real crisis I'm sure he does
now Tommy oh but you back to Miami bar
yeah I'm gonna look like Paulo coast
after six weeks yeah like I wonder how
much Jesus Christ I wonder how much of
change you get you know from Anibal your
body's gonna look exactly like I'm gonna
look like then six weeks I wonder if
it's just mild change you know like yeah
I don't know what I was going to say
we'll see what happens I mentioned my
body just eats it up and I look like
[ __ ] the rock you might and then I'm
like the neck I think you would I think
if you did the COS Tara its he's doing
you want her I would definitely still be
on a clean diet
John I do you my
that's more than that that's me I'm the
lab there's other [ __ ] going on with
this [ __ ] Yoker what first of all
that's years down the road because we
get along is here is in the right big -
yeah yeah that's a lot of that's a holy
[ __ ] totally with a necklace like that
dude I don't think I should do that bro
I do
cuz I'm dude Hollywood doing the ski you
know I've always wanted to I'm gonna
look like Thor you've always wanted to
be shredded that's what happens that's a
stretching up a lot of the women a lot
of the female CrossFit athletes all of
them do have are yeah I've heard a lot
of the IG models you see with like
blonde ass and stuff they do anavar
really yeah get that stomach I met a guy
I met a guy who knows his way around the
the gear the gear steroids for the kid
cares up the Garen you use tell me he's
like dude nine times ten kilos chicks
ear like you really shred all the time
to a lot of them run Anna barking super
mild summative supermodel is he can do
anything for a [ __ ] jack-o'-lantern
like me I want to see what happens cuz
your receptors are wide open I know a
lot about steroid talk
why don't hear your bro your receptors
are wide open your your lats it's gonna
be interesting to see what happens to
you because you're so bam bam strong to
begin with like doing a little [ __ ]
like I wonder if your test is low if
your test is though I can't imagine if
you did test do although everybody can
[ __ ] what they say now is that a lot of
times you'll go oh my testosterone is
low do you know that high levels of
mercury or low levels of zinc you can
have a huge effect on your testosterone
and when you bring that or some people
just don't sleep much and if you're not
sleeping you're a [ __ ] did you sleep
pretty good yeah dude I'm gonna look
like these everybody I look like [ __ ]
before but so that guy I'm ready off the
better start from them yeah God he got
shreds City yeah I don't believe it's
just an apart with those guys but who
knows it's a strict diet - I think that
looks dumb some of it is just like oh
there you go the American flag I see no
change sir just a different angle and
different lighting yeah and you put your
tits up dude should I start doing an or
that's me on the left right now well we
need to do a little doctor talk to
I don't have to get going in our office
and I think it's the wrong order no
that's very weird chin if it would did
what's the what's the con I think I look
at him and me everyone told me I do
anavar and clen and what clenbuterol
it's called a clear bra
it smells out the clear clears a rub bra
Avon clear the clearest clenbuterol no
it's not broke it up cleanse cleanse
Clem you know the clears the I heard the
Klan I get your uh what Barry Bonds was
taken apparently no he's not dude he was
Clem just cut like hype up increases
you're the fan what the [ __ ] it does bro
who do you have any questions my stairs
you talk to me no I got oh look at that
computer isn't a steroid but has some
property similar to those of Alma such
as promote increased muscle mass check
yeah dude these properties Cambria has
been used in livestock to increasing
amount of lean muscle well I can buy it
right and call that nuclear the heart
rate blood pressure clinton will by
increasing the heart rate blood pressure
that ain't good that's not going to
crease the metallic energy and overall
body temps caused by to burn more energy
dude
people sweat on it it's good stuff I
sweat a lot already they cause cardiac
hypertrophy enlarged heart of a pencil
series former heart damage okay yeah
anything get the shred city you know you
have to everybody know you don't want to
do that you're a big guy you don't need
to [ __ ] with your heart like that and I
need to look in there anavar apparently
doesn't cause
charges ubers you don't want to be
drinking on it you if if those IG
[ __ ] can do it you don't think I can
yeah you can baldness acne not too
worried about any of that I could
actually use some thinner my hair up
drinkin testicles this Maiden were the
worst psychics
not because I want big pet you dude big
balls is nice I'm gonna call I'm gonna
call my buddy who works with this stuff
a lot it ever has lower and tragic
effects and others that's why you would
like your boss to see what I were tell
you this whatever to people you take
stories when you [ __ ] everything like
no you actually lower sex right still
yeah
that's why you would like experience a
lower sex drive tiredness even muscle
lost after stop oh
there's nothing okay it's more
pronounced if you bulk put anavar
another stairs at the same time but but
I would need some side out some sort of
post cycle that means that run gear
after oh I'm sorry you got it you gotta
bring back to your normal levels right
right well high blood cholesterol it
changed the way your body house fat
increases your bad cholesterol while
decreasing your good cos all those how
do you know it's all about I don't know
it's all about using a little bit ultra
moderation yeah it's all about reading
it out worrying about you thought about
getting shredded not worrying about the
car yeah well let's see what happens oh
I would assume Anna bars better free
then cut the bread and die in science
inside I would say it's better than
whiskey and I drink twice a night I
drink whiskey I feel great welcome with
a headache side effects and women if
you're a woman you will grow dick with a
good oh forget about having kids at
least but not last Android can take down
if you want to have someone call you
daddy loves you for truly right okay
that's a bad one well like you always
get it back take posts like this day
even even if anniversaries didn't one
the save as Hannah bollocks Terrace be
used there must be better options out
there right that was my number one
question for a very long time until I
found oh this is a ad for some bride and
for all a safe and legal god damn it
they got Carolyn my god they got you
dude
I was let down the rabbit hole dude were
you shooting this past weekend dude I
was shooting how's it going man um I
shot something with Chris D'Elia
for my bookie calm that's cool
yep and then I got all my pics wrong for
my bookie job this week and I did a
photo shoot for schooled and there's
nothing more boring than doing that I
know in photo pool get-ups
yeah that's just not what I people who
want to be models I can't imagine any
more boring in the world than Biddle
model I mean just all of it is just like
joongki um so I did all that my son had
a little birthday party how old is he
eight a little q-tip oh did you get him
I just
but mainly like you know like what's the
action figures and video games good to
be those kids with video games bro
Trouble Man
[ __ ] man trying to keep them off it I
mean we do but it's not easy because you
are not competing they are these [ __ ]
video game doesn't program to mess with
your child's brain and I don't know a
kid out there that doesn't play
fortnight and all these simulations you
get these little hoes in the sports man
your kids not the sport type that is he
please playing no he's more of the song
type right like that yeah but he's but
he plays tennis soccer II there's all
the sports I'm gonna get him in a
jujitsu I might take him to kenny
Florian's place it's supposed to have a
good kids program great kids broken rock
great rock Meraki rocky yeah I'm gonna
take him there
I want him to do he he he he had a
little he got a little bullied at the at
baseball he's got a really good hand-eye
coordination he was hitting the ball
really well it's so impressed but there
are two big kids that were just mean
kids get mean kids are vicious and yeah
and I had to kind of watch it it was the
hardest thing I've ever gone through it
bummed me it's tough not to get involved
it bums me I'll say something to the did
and my kids tall good-looking kid he's
he's athletic but this these kids were
thick ease you know and they were they
were just boring they were they were
just being boys and they saw them that's
how boys bond yeah Mike I had to I had
to just watch it it take you I just want
I told my son I said just you know you
got to just deal with it I mean just he
figured it out he figured it out but it
was hard and it bummed me out you know
when you see her nothing because my
son's good boy you know he's just sweet
and funny he's a silly goose like me and
but some kids don't get that and then
they know some kid can't hit him for no
reason of sock doing as he was walking
by hit her in the stomach that's just
mean and hey my son is what was that for
he started to cry it's like what I was
like what the [ __ ] what I was having a
good time he'd even know what wood is
for and it's just it killed me man you
and the coach took the two boys aside I
didn't get involved the coach took the
two boys inside guys what's going on
here you know and then it was a bummer
yeah it's tough man kids being kids I
guess yeah it's [ __ ] tough yeah yeah
good punch to the stomach a knife
punching tough
good punch to the tummy Tuffy up like my
kid you know he's very happy for in
favorite race 3 and like we're at this
play place in Century City and he's like
dad look at my friend is an older kid
you think that look he might heal he
makes friends everywhere I look to my
friend and then they climb top thing
goes he goes hey he was he didn't know
his name it's a friend look that's my
mom and my dad look that's my dad that's
my mom I'm the kids always I can't give
up like oh no they don't care how be
cool I know they idolize all the kids my
son gets older loves all the kid sees
got a beard who's like hey friend hey
friend it's my mom dad and two kids oh
yeah my son is birthday party every kid
come come see my bearded dragon you drag
him upstairs
this [ __ ] lizard is like this pig you
put 12 crickets he's 12 crickets five
mealworms five super worms a day these
[ __ ]
they don't look it is easy it's cute
through yeah they stink they have
crickets do um
bearded dragons are cool yes that's
where you got to feed them can I ask you
a question you're making break down the
fight which the two-hour show Steve Amir
to its best heavyweight of all time uh
yeah there's argument for that for sure
how's that do you do you think that did
you find my way did you find the way DC
was fighting him toward the end very
strange did you feel he what DC does but
I felt like DC like he kind of sees red
and just keeps coming forward no not at
all he just like DC's whole things like
embracing the grind and ste payout
grinded him he just keeps you've sparked
alums he just keeps coming forward
though he does but but I wouldn't win
hands down against steep a I thought to
myself he's walking into a right hand
like they died he just didn't respect it
enough and yeah eventually caught up
with a man you know yeah eventually
caught up with you know who loses out
the most in all this right john jones
cuz you never you see john verse DC now
no see how much money he would have made
off that so that's that's out that's
gone john now really the only super
fight left for john john just steeping I
don't think John John eat him alive
Romani stay alive I have even a fight
what yeah I was watching I went oh man I
bet Jon's watch this training goes I'll
go too heavy really yeah I would say the
opposite
how so DC beat him for every minute of
that fight except for that fourth round
yeah you know what John would do John
would I don't planned it I don't think
John hits his hardest Daniel and I think
steep a walks him down and oh no way
punches his lights out mm-hmm no thing
about John John was pushing DC back no
one puts his DC back DC bull eats the
bayonet dead boys deep in the Octagon
and thing we also think what John well
also judged Daniels 240 pounds in that
fight you know what do you think Java
coming it he I guess he walked it off is
that how much he weighs well I read it
hmm if I'm John's camp on watch I go oh
yeah we'll go take that belt Wow
really yeah and you don't think it's a
fight I think it's a good fight but I
think John dissect them eat them alive
take him down take him get it John took
down DC dude yeah yeah he did John beat
the [ __ ] out of him Wow
I do you think that's the fight that
happens if your jaw like the only super
fight for John's that and for if it all
depends what DC is gonna do so let's say
DC retires so the only super fight you
have John steep Bay you have Frances
gone Oh John you have steep a Frances to
there's not a lot out there for a man so
DC lose that fight it [ __ ] up a lot
for other people but hmm maybe I'm I
might see John as a 205 pound fighter I
don't see him as a heavyweight but you
know he beat DC twice right did be DC
twice handedly yeah knocking him out the
head kick knocked him out excuse me sir
yeah and all dogs bars with this heavy
weights and you can make an argument
almost for DC being the greatest
heavyweight enzyme of all time Charlie
go up there's gotta sighs Cain Velasquez
you got to go up there
the day's gotta pay him to go up there
oh go and match up why is there's
nothing for Matt light-heavyweight
there's no so you don't think John you
don't think John's afraid of steep a god
no uh-uh cuz he messed eBay just flat
foot it's state they shot he takes shots
a lob and my feeling is he can take he's
so durable he takes anything John gives
him closes that distance and starts
punching him in the face
that's that's what I got some out in the
clear yes Oh cuz you think oh you think
John is a greco whose phenomenal in the
clinch who submitted who have submitted
Glover Teixeira in the clinch Ledo
Machida in the clinch heat destroys guys
but destroys guys in the clinch Steve a
is not a big heavyweight was he to you
training them six for six no six three
six three not sitting 1440
big boy he looked very big when I saw
him just wide you know giant head big
head yeah I mean six CS 6-3 they always
they always exaggerate Daniel's not 511
no why did I do that
but John comes at all every bit of six
all sports do that right all sports do
that yeah John six four six five I'd say
six five six for Bill Young very
intrigued right now Steve pate John's
the fight yeah very intriguing but
there's nothing for John at light
heavyweight at heavyweight this now is
left it everywhere anybody there's
Rhea's vs. Weidman the winner that
outside that there's literally nothing
he's beat everyone one the--like six
there's nothing nominal yeah you know
for John's legacy go up there and you
know get it man
cars blades mm-hmm interesting
no you got nothing for any paper you
think that they'll be in the UFC you're
doing John for steepen you got a dejar
vs t pay depend what DC wants to do but
DC's out for a wild man
interesting right did he get injured or
he's who's that for a while deep a DC
he's a frog who got knocked down off
down didn't he's also four teeth um
every time yeah it should be
let me ask for a well great comment if I
was here ahead of him I would just
thoughts got a great career ahead of him
so we know that's a great cuz amazing
he's good he doesn't need to do anything
yeah he's amazing DC one [ __ ] Kenneth
wouldn't life man hell yeah um good
fight though yeah my first gift card in
life well an idea is Tomas veto this is
a hat huh yeah that'll happen
if DFC pays Nate what he's worth
otherwise you can have another long
holdout mm-hmm which is a bummer but if
I'm if I'm Mazda I want to hold out for
the title shot I don't want to fight
Nate you're not getting title shot you
see you told that you're fighting me
okay Kobe Kobe use mine yep yeah would
you guys do this weekend cat mmm nothing
much I'm still kind of recovering I got
my boyfriend sick so I had to take care
of him for the weekend I'm sick
mm-hmm because last week I was sick and
then what kind of sickness all that love
making all that lovemaking I think it's
just the common cold I don't know I had
a crazy fever hmm Jim Welch in was in
Portland with a day drinking whiskey you
some video really oh yeah you got some
whiskey Ronix a lot of with you the boy
drinks a lot of it yeah what kind of lot
of whiskey I don't know what when you
have exhaust has got some v I went
through that down the whiskey hall in
scopa there's some good [ __ ] oh we're
drinking bullet cuz they didn't have
Buffalo Trace yeah only spot that
usually you have a bottle with Buffalo
Trace for me my boy I don't have it my
boy Aaron and Craig they came out with
some [ __ ] they're like try this let's
now try this you know it's just a key
[ __ ] I said Derek last night to scopa oh
you did yeah yeah Duke boasted his girl
there's got some there's some there's
some [ __ ]
what else did we do that night Jen we
came to the show do we hang out during
the day no because I got there right
when the show is about to start he saw
that night we couldn't do anything
member oh the proud boys yeah I mean
like Chappelle was really worried that
something might happen so he was like
yeah I'd rather not so so what street
daro well cops told us to go home
right cuz they know we're restaurant
open or not really look I met in strip
club was but my restaurant my hotel was
phenomenal that great food everything's
done where'd you stay what hotel dossier
does here good hotel phenomenal because
I got a get a list of the cuz you guys
cuz J looks into it and find some good
places yeah we see Kansas City had one
of the best hotels I've ever seen I was
like some of these places have amazing
but you didn't say their rights I didn't
because they eat a whale at the hotel no
cuz I'm comedy venue but I don't know
you've been doing this for 30 years
that's the [ __ ] hotel this is OCA the
sea-air that dude and that that
restaurant there they had these kebabs
they had a lamb kabob tzatziki sauce on
there hot sauce all to see oh dude so I
just ate there but you're so much cuter
about I haven't cheated yet how do you
feel phenomenal you do fantastic huh I
got the whole staff and my guys boo do
doughnuts demon touch up your didn't
even think about it now do you um I'm
achieved yet man do you eat what do you
get for like food vegetables vegetables
I can't have broccoli but I can have
like a broccoli that's not cute too many
carbs Wow and broccoli Jesus certain
peppers there's a lot of carbs but I can
have like spinach see our gifts so you
do that yeah a lot of kale and you feel
great phenomenal My Mind's clear huh
faster thing you know would not be
considered that's a grain what yams can
you beat yams no bro you can teach em no
all right what does keto exactly just
fab you saw that and fat yeah protein of
that hold on okay there you can have you
can never love Carlos you know tomatoes
eggplant avocado
I feel like that'd be such a healthy
diet just that and meat in the phone do
feel fantastic
I don't feel the best is I awoke rind
you're allowed to do this party
are not allowed to have those it says
beetroot sweet potato you can't have
this these are green and what what but
what is what is 10 grams of carbs but it
those are carbs oh I see yeah you can't
have those on keto I was not keto just
shown you how many carbs are in those
I'm putting on a little tiny bit of my
weight under my chin as we talked you
have a nut sack enough and I I have a
lantern to go huh no my Asus pills is
hiding you know by work today
was it the pit was it the panther well
might the sides of my where my kidneys
are that Dara tell dr. Milo haunt you
hunters I've never had fat you get some
saddlebags the other day dude I'm at
this say some the other day no man I'm
feeling it's a cure I'm weak about this
stuff
did the old love handles I'm getting
people are going hey rink love your rink
oh you old wrinkled cauliflower cabbage
avocado top 10 keto vegetables
cauliflower Locklear our avocado like
cabbage righto you can with broccoli and
spinach
I like that email should I be careful
eating too many 5 grams green greens I
got my girl's dad on it and he's lost 8
pounds and he goes I'm come kind of hit
a plateau you what what are you eating
is one of the morning he goes well in
the morning I eat about 14 strawberries
about you know two handfuls of blueberry
you know sugar that is do you Israel
can't that's not Quito man no you have a
few berries
yeah few and I go when I go and then I
go hold on but that can't just be like
what what are you doing with your of
coffee us I just put creamer I go what
crema is it here's oh it's the the quick
mate hazelnut yeah oh my god you just
might see in a snicker bar during the
day yeah
you look at my sugars how much like a
tablespoon it's like 12 grand for a
spoon and he's dumping I go your coffee
like you kind of on the lighter side you
put a lot cream you know sell yeah
you're basing to snicker bars in your
coffee every morning he's really yeah
that's right that's right I think I just
don't know man I'm always amazed like I
came to have
the lie I can have some of the
unsweetened almond milk well you know
remember on my car I don't know if you
know my cholesterol was high like 165 I
was like what the [ __ ] am i doing
well I was I didn't know that that I was
eating so I wouldn't eat as much cheese
and stuff but I was taking a lot of
avocados a lot of olive oil a shitload
of almond milk I was putting almond
looking everything drinking like you
know glide a little shits like that
shit's like heavy and fats and it
actually boost your omega-6 fatty acids
so your cholesterol goes way up so I
stopped doing as much as that and I feel
better fish your skin's done them go a
little huh that picture you and bilious
that me idli Co Brian's officially
creepy yeah I know y'all I was like this
you look like Epstein didn't you say
that - Sam Triple E is it weird that
Brian looks exactly like Jeff Epstein if
it please how about that [ __ ] the
conspiracy theories around that guy yeah
what up dude huh but so they states did
the forensic people said he definitely
hung himself well my friend who is Ed my
friend there's a guy who hit me up
behind my TM and he said I was a prison
nurse for 20 years
psychiatric ward and and in suicide wash
so he would watch a lot of people since
this kind of thing with sexual predator
offenders when they know that there's
there's not even freedom is not gonna be
freedom they kill themselves he said he
saw nude so many suicides
if you ever want to talk about why this
was clearly a suicide and there's no way
and why wasn't he watched he said cuz
it's a prison and it's not that our over
there understand already even if you
watch everybody somebody every 30
minutes it's no problem because they've
had plenty of suicides when that was the
case everybody wants us to be something
but um but it's too hard don't Tim Kenny
had a good point cuz he was saying how
he goes man the guy hung himself in the
Fetty broke bones in his in his throat
and Tim K is like god I don't know man
broke broken broken neck from that the
guy goes yeah people hang himself
break that bone all the time Tim goes
not from that from the the height that
he dropped with
a [ __ ] curtain it'd be tough to
generate that for he's an older man
though you never know who knows how
about this I'm at the I'm at the Laugh
Factory with D'Elia and this girl reals
herself by you know when you will
yourself by your hand your leg is in a
cast but you have your knee on top of
the on the scooter yeah yeah soon when
you have knee surgery maybe I don't know
what yeah ankle so pretty pretty woman
probably a little bit older and audio
not older 35 but very pretty and I say
she goes kind of so great something nice
about my stand-up something I said oh
thanks I go what happened your foot and
she goes oh you'll never believe it and
I go what happened she goes well because
it was it was wrapped in a weird thing
it wasn't in like a regular booty and I
said I said what happened she goes well
I was in Thailand and an elephant leaned
kneeled on my foot I was petting it in
the element foot and I go oh my god is
your foot crushed she goes well yeah but
also the skin on the all the skin on the
top my foot just peeled off all because
when the thing [ __ ] leaned on it it's
just wet [ __ ] and the skin just went
rolled off so the top hope you're about
a pressure oh yeah all the skin on the
front just goes well see you later yeah
why don't we till pull the skin off and
then why don't we crush all the bones
while we're at it flat your foot out sir
she's all bunched up and the elephant
looked like it was about to roll on are
like leaning on her because she was
scratching it it was like grasping a
[ __ ] thing good which is like I like
that yeah they had they it was hard to
go if you're a guy that was like wait
what happens no idea I know you know he
ripped the skin off I was just leaning
on that [ __ ] muster
well I mean horses will step on your
foot then when you're brushing them
they'll just make a mistake and step on
your foot and it's so painful there's a
picture locked out
I show you this picture when my wife got
bitten by by a horse on the ass yeah
remember that yeah dad she was bending
over and she shouldn't have been in the
stool he was in a bad mood and she sent
me a picture of her ass and oh my god I
don't post her
is a sure spot don't with elephants they
kill you
horses close and kill you yeah how [ __ ]
with any of them yeah Jesus Christ man
that's like my buddy Bob Bob at the
airport this very heavy woman is with
her husband and Bob's like mr. strong
man she got hit by a car
it pushed her it hit her lightly but she
fell back I think it pinned her foot and
she fell back and and he goes uh he goes
he goes and guess what Brian I goes her
foot came on and I go what he goes yep
her foot came off right I said he goes
it was only being held on by her like
her pants but it the broad like that
remember when it happened to Silva yeah
it went like that and it kind of it only
the skin was holding on to it then and
she goes oh my foot and her husband
started to panic and he goes I got you
and she was too big for a husband to
pick up but he's really strong he just
picked her up she was up takes it on
hold he had thick he thick you just hold
her foot older foot and held the foot on
there but I flipped my boom right at the
airport she went into shock the tug goes
yeah the guy was super rich my friend
had no money is I couldn't give you
money and no is that [ __ ] I should have
taken some money Jesus yes that's a
weird thing when your foot comes you
guys broke anything
yeah yeah well yeah like oh there's
nothing I know hey when you're doing
loops on your motorcycle when you're
flipping in here now my finger you saw
right in a song and oh wow how'd you
hurt your finger yeah it's so this one
here I broke this one and then this one
but this one's more crooked than the
other one YouTube oh I'm human bone well
don't answer it like come on dude
but you've only broke two fingers right
hey I got job so that's why really tell
my skateboard yeah
they threw bikes at me and then I you
know won by kami and I fell down and
they're like you never have broken
anything right years of sports nope nope
get simple Franco's
face no my nose and then
damn near every finger dance or bony
finger no relighting breath not from for
them all so much you like football you
break your hands all the time no fingers
no not really
huh that's about it my neck little great
have you broke every broke anything yet
no the only thing I can remember is I
got a bad burn when I was like seven in
Vietnam from a motorcycle the exhaust
nice awesome I still have the burns
right yeah I have a scar to the hallway
I know miss girl was riding on the bike
for boyfriends motorcycles super fast
and fell off and you know that's good
off your skin no broke my nose
I had to have an operation on my nose
which was a lot of fun that's a good
time you ever have your nose stuffed yep
and with trains that's great so had that
couldn't breathe out of my nose for a
long time getting kicked in the [ __ ]
kicked by a roundhouse kick that was
good could you sick one day sparring I
turn on my guard good let me go back I
he grabs me and goes Kent kicks me in
the [ __ ] lady's a pod casts on it
what have you broken the earth and then
I broke a broken I've dislocated that
thumb which I never got fixed and I just
been in class yeah I have I was Cathy's
tooth not bad these two knuckles wasn't
a cast it can I was and my leg was in a
cast cuz I twirling him do they still
cast you up there - have they advanced
when I was when I when I tore a ligament
I was in a real cast yeah okay and they
get all itchy and like you'll scratch
and the stick up yeah like a wood hanger
yeah I can just get a pencil and the
people still love like right on them and
stuff I did that olds I like making
things I still have my cast someone yeah
these fiberglass
let's do some current events fiberglass
do you think it'd be advanced technology
oh you guys look at that
let's get it cool all right what do you
got
hey B did you know your teeth move every
as you get older not just your throat
gives up yeah
teeth start to yeah they start to look
like a ship yeah but you got to spend a
lot of money on braces no you don't man
I want to get my teeth fixed when I was
like dude I can't be wearing braces then
someone some little teeth birdie said
dude what about candid you need clear or
turn ative two braces
yeah the clear I'll turn alternative
braces yeah bro and guess what I'm
all-in do it they have they have an
experienced Orthodox license to your
stage create a treatment plan boy up
they create a 3d preview of how your
teeth will look when your treatments are
done that's why candidate for both of us
so and then you approve the 3d preview
yep that's what I did eyeliner show you
there clear and there's yep clear
there's no hassle you don't have to go
to orthodontist office candidate cost
sixty five percent less than bracing and
for every a liner purchased candied
donates $25 just smile trained who
brings safe hun percent free cleft lip
and palate treatments to children around
them you know what I love about that as
I give money to a smile training now and
I can do it and fix your own teeth you
it's true be honest yeah I need and I
need I need to go girls went back to the
shade they did oh it didn't last no and
I got to go back in sweat 10 huh and I'm
gonna tell you the company I used was
it's a lot you gotta go to the doctor
you have to I'm yours is fake do
yourself forget your chanted get
straight up brighter teeth on like Bryan
Callen and that was just six months damn
learn more at candid cocom slaps fighter
and use the code fighter to get seventy
five dollars off that's candid co.com
slash fighter code fighter for seventy
five dollars off I'm on this fixture
grill I'm doing this yo B it's back to
school you know what that means
oh traffic but also a sale from on it
50% off really fit your sent off so for
you Pappas out there or you Mama's maybe
you're stressed out with your kid going
back to school get yourself a little
stuff
no something self its yourself a little
our body I realized maybe maybe total
human new mood what's up some freaking
gut health yeah got health maybe want
some shrimp tag crew oil maybe some gut
hell
as crow is bad for you nobody what about
some earth grown nutrients either way
select the items are 50% off maybe need
some nutrition maybe need some fitness
care apparel whenever you want 50% off
back-to-school sale starts right now you
Kido Papa's out there they got your fat
butter they got water your hot sauce
they got it all man go to audit dot-com
slash fighter right now the
back-to-school sale starts now
50% off gives you some on a.com slash
fighter that is not it
here we go I start over so popular so
did you guys see on Twitter Whitney
Cummings as tweets about somebody trying
to extort her some piece of [ __ ] yeah
but even the picture they're trying to
extort which it was a story off her
Instagram and it's like that's what you
really extort her with that what was it
it was a Instagram story yeah she was in
the bath I believe in she was taking a
story kind of like this and her nipple
happened to be in it when she noticed
she ended up taking it down but there
were a couple people who actually
recorded it screenshot it and they were
trying to extort her for money she ended
up releasing it herself saying that one
she thinks the people who were trying to
extort her I think she's more famous
than she actually is and - she doesn't
care if anybody sees her nipples and in
response a lot of people were really
cool about it and they Burt actually
pasted up a picture of his balls not I
give leaves where did it take it down
he's some losers yeah money you pieces
of [ __ ] it's hilarious and the pictures
like that's where your next order
that's been ain't [ __ ] man Whitney's
coming on here huh she's coming to her
on Wednesday I'll talk to her about it
then yes Kyle was yeah let's talk to her
about a kid's dad just this once
this Wednesday what else he get so a man
in New York went to the Rochester
Airport and while he walked through TSA
he was given a note by one of the women
working he was kind of confused when he
saw it because he goes to the air
were very often for work and he just
kind of grabbed them no and he was gonna
leave he overhears the woman laughing
sang hey aren't you gonna open it aren't
you gonna open it
he opens the note and it says you ugly
no and he obviously he looked at her and
they were kind of her and a couple other
workers were giggling their friends
though no he said that he was offended
by it or anything and that it was pretty
clear to him that she was just trying to
play a joke but he decided to actually
tell her manager just because yeah she
ended up getting fired but he just did
it from the standpoint of well I didn't
find it offensive but you never know who
else could have given the note he was
trying he's not probably savor hey let
just she takes liberties yeah but you
ugly yeah
no watch it you have a picture of the
guy yeah you're nosy like really hideous
no not you struck wait is that the girl
on the right there no you'll see her
right there
I got handed a note I didn't really
think of too much of it I just kind of
kept going
about ten minutes to the note and they
called back to me are you gonna open
that are you gonna open it are you gonna
look or something like that
eventually he opened it and the workers
started laughing oh it's it you ugly
with three exclamation marks
he says at first he just thought it was
strange but then decided just because it
didn't know him doesn't mean it wouldn't
hurt other people in the face so where
does she know no lecture you know they
don't know each other at all and also
she's no peach to lie but what was it's
Ted is the most bizarre thing I can
think it let's I mean fun is also
awesome nobody's in the line I'll say
you're just
like this the one guy first of all you
feel like a loser you're lonely
traveling there's nobody around then oh
by the way you ugly [ __ ] off I'm
traveling I'm probably tired it's
probably early in the morning we did no
one around and no one else is in on the
joke you ugly it's just her and then
she's then she's fast you know grammar
sucks I think she she had this in her
pocket for a while and wanted to wait
until someone came and he happened to be
the person because there's nobody in
line there's absolutely no one there
it's about the most bizarre thing I've
seen I don't know what to say about I
it's so reckless and just like not not
funny at all the funny part is there's
no one around
yeah okay and then should I you know are
you gonna read that he's like cool oh
she's all he I mean all right thanks
cheeto cheeto wouldn't kill her what
else we get so last week Mia Khalifa the
former porn star came out and said that
she only made 12 grand from her very
shortly lived adult film career and a
lot of porn anymore no she said tell me
I'll make him I'm watching reruns axis
rock she says that for she made about a
dozen videos within the span of a month
or two more than that Playgirl oh she
only made a dozen but what ends up
happening is that people are then taking
the videos and reposting them on other
accounts so it seems like she's still in
active yeah I thought she was but a lot
of people she's done working it months
well she could do it now she should go
into another one for a shitload of money
and I just uploaded on her own page well
she has a great career outside of porn
now and what uh you know she had a
sports show on I believe it was either
barstools or complex something like that
she had she's doing pretty well for
herself now she's hot juicy shaker's
dude yeah I see that you want a
restaurant she's actually wild your boy
she's actually well-known for the video
she did with hijab she did like a Muslim
related porn video that gone girl I roll
those breasts it's real real big yeah
who's that guy
legend Oh where's she from England no
she's from here the United States he's
just from Florida sexy look at it right
there you never seen her work right no
she was suck the skin off a dick dude
really
she's never - horn huh I don't watch
porn no I don't watch porn i I've seen
all her work is I'm gonna watch porn now
I watch your words like it's a quitting
Tarantino really oh yeah they're the
headman's little surprise I haven't
watched point and so [ __ ] long well
because you're older I know this year's
birthday I just really haven't watched
porn I don't know how long I told you
one time I was nice for my dad I was
watching porn my father was going what
is all this porn I'm like you know
laughs Oscar I was like I don't I was
watching but I it was just that was a
one-time thing
dude they told her I doubt that play but
they tell her that you tell me those
amazing pornos she did like there's like
you can watch somewhere three black guys
like team up on her more than sometimes
I love you don't got 12 grand
she made 12 videos each video was about
a thousand for a flat rate but this was
before she started popping off this is
before she became popular and so the big
debate with this is should porn
companies give her residuals or the
amount of work she's doing cuz she's
still to this day such a big name and
porn even though she's been out of it
for years I had no idea she's out she's
big in like Asia I'm sure she's big here
Brian
yet yonder she's huge here yeah well
she's fantastic
pretty girl Wow I don't know she's out
she's uh and now she has a career
yes doing other stuff kind of I think I
don't know how many there way how many
followers have some crazy 16 I'm so
crazy
Jesus Christ she's huge she's making a
fortune then what else we got so Sarah
Silverman released last week that she
actually got dropped from a movie
because of an old blackface sketch that
she did back in 2007 on her show
[ __ ] really a bunch of they went
back into that is such [ __ ] she
ended up saying that she after a couple
years with the sketch of being out she
did feel bad about it and she doesn't
stand by the sketch anymore but she is
bummed out that she got pulled yeah but
you know you can't say sorry or anything
else you're just you I think it's really
scary odd thing that's invaded the life
primarily and the right will mimic it
it's so odd it's perversion it's really
look how righteous I am now I'm gonna
press refresh all day long see how many
likes I get in my righteousness I don't
stand by the blackface sketch I'm
horrified by it I can't really you can
nowadays you can't apologize nowadays
here it doesn't matter your cancel if
you did it but they just take you out
you're cancelled let me see it's called
cancel culture so the [ __ ] far left
drives me crazy this way it's like
there's no such thing but but given
let's get was there's a sketch it was a
sketch about is it more difficult to be
Jewish or is it more difficult to be
black and that's why she did the
blackface that so she got fired over
that I mean did such [ __ ] that they
would fire you cuz apparently she's
racist you know apparently you know yeah
they met at Robert Downey jr. for
playing a black man in traffic ladder
he's your hero and iron man you know
it's like these people are not racist
you're fighting the wrong fight man
you're fighting the wrong fight
it's virtue signaling at its worst and
it's always the most woke people are
white privileged liberal kids it's like
who go to these colleges where it's sooo
if you're so liberal I'll tell you what
if you're so woke and you you're in this
like you're at Harvard and Yale where
all these all this [ __ ] is coming out of
give up your tuition and give it to
somebody who could go to give it to a
person of color who go to a City College
give up your tuition you're spending a
hundred thousand dollars a year that's
five hundred thousand dollars you could
spend so get where's your where's your
put your money where your mouth is you
know do it that's such a bummer okay
what else she's not in your movie I mean
unbelievable she's one of the most
talented people on there yeah
and that was how many years ago ten oh
I'm sorry twelve years ago
she did a sketch yeah it's okay though
that just it's just it was just because
she's gonna do it nothing doesn't matter
[ __ ] hypocrisy I won't see that movie
out there that much no what else yet Jen
[ __ ] you guys for firing her no this is
in Florida and this woman she had two
different dates I'll show you the first
one the first one was for some reason
she was with a date and then he got
pulled over and he said I might get
arrested it was for some sort of like
you know ticket vile or you know some
sort of thing on his car that they
wanted to check okay I'll just play free
stop sticks to disable it it's actually
funnier when you listen to it Coast
about 2:00 a.m. Thursday only to learn
the driver bailed out into some woods
leaving the passenger a woman to face
the consequences we are not identifying
her because she's not charged with a
crime turns out the woman had just met
the Orlando area man on a dating website
and stopped at this Palm Coast Denny's
for dinner on the way to her it gets
better when a deputy tried to stop the
vehicle for a tag violation travellish
Nate told the woman he'd go to jail so
he raced off he was exceeding the speed
limit driving very erratically she was
very scared in the vehicle she told us
he got away though so yeah she knew him
by two different first names and cygnus
us so wrong on Thursday was the victim
in a different incident also involving a
man last month an incident that turned
violent and was caught on camera what
that instance a man's woman was seeing
but trying to get away from Fidel store
threw himself took it up attacked her
when she got out pounding her knocking
her unconscious he did that to her a
month ago a different day different hey
a different person Russians do more than
knock door a knocked her out and then a
month later she went on a date with this
guy and then police pursuit and he ran
away
now that guy should be cancelled right
that guy should go to jail that guy
would have yeah they get should not be
any movies yeah that's a different story
that's real file both those guys maybe
yeah all right this is a cute one it's a
little bit long though but it's a father
interrogating this girl's date through
the ring on the door is a great ad for
ring all right
[Music]
okay all right all right all right okay
[Music]
okay all right okay
[Music]
goodbye all right money what we have
enough money this is [ __ ] Graham doing
this with my daughter but technically
you don't have $2.00 got some sweater
puppies on her hey hey that's his
daughter bro take it easy all right
watch this last part it's good to take a
picture right now
no this in front of the house I'm
watching I'm talking stuff take a
picture right now see open the door for
the door
good job the other daughter I'm not sure
he was talking I think right now that's
funny right yeah I'll listen man he's
not taking chances this I saw nature
nature is metal it's just really cool
from San Diego Zoo I'll just show it to
you a bird swimming in a polar bear oh
yeah look how fast I did it the [ __ ] was
that duck thinking silicon okay the kids
are terrified by the way
even if who's going yeah feathers and
all huh the way he sneaks up on him
so fast oh god that would be terrifying
Pok man that's what they do remember I
went to the zoo one time and I with my
son there's just two rhinos barking I'm
talking really a dick the size of a
ruler and this thing laughs and men
really pause laughing what are they
doing they're wrestling
I want the wrestling they're at Papa the
wrestling they're wrestling all the
parents are laughing their asses off
you ever watch mountain gorillas little
one little ones wrestle there there they
have the best technique in mountain
gorillas they have like they do Granby
rules to do all kinds of wrestling what
else you guys go this is a scary one
that I saw Dale Earnhardt jr. in a plane
crash did you guys see this plane crash
no well you don't really see the actual
crash we see what happens right after it
so the the plane for whatever reason the
landing gear the right side it collapsed
so it hit the ground like twice and then
it came to a stop like it after a fence
and by the freeway if the private was on
it yes private plane and it was only
like a two-hour drive if it was from
where he was at so a 20-minute flight
it's a really short flight but that's
this is the aftermath and I'll show you
like this right here this is them
exiting the plane after it crashed so
they're fine yeah but look how bad this
is so this just this just crash right so
these guys are coming from the freeway
find help yep fuel get holy [ __ ] man
thank everyone on board is fine though
Wow check this off so they're still in
the plane right now oh my god all right
let me focus in here dude and then
you'll see this guy running back in that
plane explodes again and then this guy
falls and I look at the door pop open
holy [ __ ]
so then junior and his family yeah so
the world I think that's a pilot and
they give the daughter to the pilot so
he runs and then I think this is Dale
running
then his wife fell down hey Dale help
your Wayne back this is what I think is
so hard to tell though and then their
dog actually makes it out too so there's
two pilots two dog the family dog made
it out two pilots and then the daughter
they all made it but how how much that
destroy your life okay lying well you
could have just died right there you're
not breathing that smoke no they barely
made it up dude barely barely made
enough thank God oh wow [ __ ] those wow
wow so [ __ ] scary yeah I hate flying
for that reason so bad Jesus Christ well
Americo plans don't really do that
though yeah that's a the private planes
do 300 crafter this year how many 300
million yeah more likely a dying the way
to work Jim yeah you [ __ ] talk about
our plane crazy you know it's gonna
crash like sky oh my god with your
families that's what happened to uh
about Dale yeah
save yourself [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't tell
but it seemed like a man what's his name
that spark and some debate on that oh
yeah
I think the pilots the pilot died and
one other person died and then you
Travis friend DJ and because of you know
all the surgeries and everything he gets
hooked opiate than died and then Travis
till this day doesn't fly in a plane
even when they perform they do tours all
over Europe he gets he leaves two months
earlier with his family with a bow take
a bow yeah Wow that'd be tough to fly
again even we're in some way guys he's a
great guy yeah you know it happened to
him he got what he's trying to escape
we got doused yeah fuel jet and then it
caught on fire you can't see it either
it's just B's burnin we can't see it
it's scary huh well you can't see it no
here's the amazing book it tells all
about it's awful man that's terrible all
right this is from I think last week or
a week and a half ago but it made a lot
of news Chris Cuomo
going after a guy because I love Chris
for this Andy he's a CNN anchor oh I
like him no I knew Chris I knew Chris
fairly well before he was Chris Cuomo no
I did I spent a lot of time with him in
New York and great guy big boy a
every big kid on his bluff he's every
bit of 6 3 maybe maybe 64 230 now all
mostly what happened yes someone at a
restaurant would call them Fredo yeah
which is a character on the Godfather
so Fredo is the brother the weak brother
and the Godfather okay afraid of when
Godfather to gets killed
okay because he turned against the
family and chose sides okay so so he was
right there like he's considered like
the rough Jill that's Nick a wheat
weakling the weak rough so he say sones
Fredo there--but yeah but it's also so
Chris comes from he's he comes from a
sees a sign of a family so Mario Cuomo
was the longtime governor of New York
and probably most vocal governor also a
governor was a great governor he always
wanted to run for president
pray connect brother now Andrew Cuomo is
is I think the current governor or was
the governor so there's that there's a
legacy Chris who is the youngest and
grew up you know in this political
family also like super good-looking was
on People magazine's sexiest guy you
know and all that but a dude a reg a
real [ __ ] guy women love that guy I
mean I remember when he was younger and
women [ __ ] love him and but he was an
athlete he was a just a good guy and a
guy's guy a [ __ ] dude now chris is
also on CNN so considered like liberal
and all that but chris is probably chris
is a dude who would just you get you
love just a regular guy hit played yeah
watch this though I loved him for this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a fan brush your fan Chris doesn't
take [ __ ] this guy you gotta love Chris
yeah you seem like gonna be a real
problem yeah they thought those guys are
such good yeah they thought he was such
[ __ ] Mia that is what's wrong with
society a bunch of [ __ ] yeah those
are the same guys who jump on Chris
Como's social media and talk [ __ ] -
exactly
you know Chris como is killing it he's
killing it no so yeah so once again once
again a very big strong kid and I think
they didn't realize that you get close
to Chris I spent a lot of time with
Quest you get close with Chris and
you're like oh you're you're a
heavyweight you're a straight-up
heavyweight and and you're you've done
sports you're all I've n you're a dude
from New York and they thought he was
gonna be this weak little [ __ ] guy
and all of a sudden he gets in your face
and the whole story tall man you love
him turn out oh my god for that Trump
ghost [ __ ] talk - huh he goes I
thought Chris was Fredo also the truth
hurts totally lost it low ratings at CNN
Trump goes yeah hold by the way here
by the way gasoline no they know this
Chris is known Trump his whole life oh
yeah so every party and they grew up in
the same journals so Chris but Chris hey
hey look at me
Chris steal your girl steal your girl
out Trump's what I hear you Chris steal
any girl not Trump Trump girl's fault
woman do you want to go with him here
here no heat no no no here's hundred G's
in just okay here here here's what I'm
gonna suck that make sure that wait
until this fall when when when Trump
isn't looking his girl moonlights with
Chris Chris Chris I don't know he's now
married but when he was a single man oh
yeah he's understand he had his choice
of he had his choice you you can see him
when he was a younger dude he was sued I
love he's ready to [ __ ] those guys I
have some reason yeah a real guys guy
that's where when I knew him back in the
day and oh wow yeah yeah that's his
brother big kid
don't worry lays what else you guys and
by the way real quick
humble never took himself seriously
never hurts
that's true never seriously nuts to say
if you if you were saying if you were to
say to him something that he goes like
you say something like you know yeah I
hear you're tough right here good
athlete somebody said something about
him doing that he goes hey bro I have
trouble waking up in the morning I say
yes I'm not he'd never was never trying
to be anything but that yeah I think
that's all the good ones that was
hilarious but I mean you want a sad one
yeah why not why not uh Cedric Benson
all right no I you know I played against
me in college you know well I don't know
we wrote it back for Texas he died of
driving a motorcycle
yeah him and I we just found out that he
had a girl on that motorcycle - they
both died
who did he run no polish on a car truck
this whatever this is a van
uh uh it was he still playing her no no
he was retired art on Austin Texas you
said you played with him are played
against against them he's in his 30s
terrible yeah they said it was so
graphic motorcycles are [ __ ] so
graphic that what they can't post the
actual video I saw a guy [ __ ] you they
ran into the car I think he got footage
of him or them trying to save him
afterwards which do graphic did ended
the car was running in a light or what I
think he lost control you know he got
busted for DUI twice already before
[ __ ] new footage obtained by TMZ you
can see at least six cars have pulled
over near the crash an appeal raced over
to help out the video shows Cedric's
burning Marshall propped up against the
driver's side door the minivan ok the
person who shot the video notes the
emergency personnel had arrived when the
video is being shot you don't see any
flashing lights keeps going down one
gives her bed in fire extinguish okay
Benson of the fire rescue short but it's
too late been since passenger were
pronounced dead on the scene through
show bets that sadly posted this picture
just hours before say by Saturday
evening Jesus Christ man I've seen I
mean two fatalities on motorcycles and
then they were right after the fact one
guy there's always on a really sunny
Sunday yeah like it was like 10:30 in
the more I'm driving up Airport Avenue
right on Bundy or somewhere I think that
was were and guys just there and I pull
up and he's lying there the cop had just
gotten there I said what happened and he
said he'd spun out and hit his head on
the curb he was just dead and then I'm
driving to San Diego or wherever just
and it's a Sunday and again there's like
a little bit of a detour and I [ __ ]
see a motorcycle it's like 10:30 again
motorcycle liner and a dude you just see
him with a sheet over him he just died
there on a Sunday morning you know
motorcycles motorcycles stuck into a
bull and so I went over there and I put
my hands on them and they're both alive
and they both alive now I we're terrible
Benson yep three same age as me man huh
it's a bummer happy one uh yeah
this FBI agent he retired on his
retirement day the kid that he rescued
22 years earlier came in since surprisin
he's now a Marine - the kid looks cool
so this kid was actually when he was
born
someone impersonated a nurse and took
him from his mom right and then no you
don't let the baby out your sight when
you have a baby you have no idea what
they're gonna do sometimes they make
them up Jesus yeah and then just
impersonating a nurse and grabbing
that's crazy anyways the the officers on
one the detective found him inside a box
at a trash dumpster type really cool man
like he'd luckily found that kid was
good yeah and this is MBM uniting a
Marine the first time Rembert cute super
cute baby never forget thankful that we
found you we found you alive in 1997
rember was two days old when he was
kidnapped from a Washington Hospital by
a woman claiming to be a nervous said
she was the nursery nurse and that they
were gonna take him to him the nursery
so I could get some sleep
not on my watch that was the last time I
saw him it was one of sours first cases
with the FBI he found baby bream pert in
a box behind a dumpster but I I pulled a
baby out of a box that was stuff I had
to take a couple deep breaths before I
started talking Rembert was reunited
with his family after high school he
joined the Marines without him I
wouldn't be where I am today a United
States Marine
Friday is Sowers last day with the FBI
he's ending his career with one of the
first people he started it with that's
great he's saying like there's hours at
his retirement party if I think that is
the perfect bookend to end seeing him
again it really just puts the the final
touch to it that's a great way to bring
with him a thank you corporal Ren verts
waited 22 years rubric you all this
one's have happened if he hadn't found
me like I want thank you for giving me
the opportunity of a life in knoxville
brittany Tarwater wvlt knew pretty cool
nothing is good stuff man said I've
saved a couple babies that's it
beware art show in cold country casino
next Saturday almost sold out dude I'm
sold out
next Saturday it's 30 minutes north of
Sacramento we Sacramento met oh yeah 30
minutes north
Oroville California that's next Saturday
Brian and myself will be doing one show
once you're only a Saturday night after
that I met the ice house are you in town
well I'm in town I am do it come on all
right
ice well Chappelle Derek is on you and
me at the ice house in Pasadena
that is September 12 that's one night
when show only and then Houston
September 22 21st aisle Road Dogg and
then Denver September 26 through 28
there you go my trans threw out the
first pitch for the Rockies sign nice I
know you know all that you know how
you're just sucking off Chris come oh
it's not come on
you really gotta say names so if you get
a flu you've got a CDS take it easy
taking Cuomo rich boy Circle he's good
Pittsburgh ten three to ten five just
one on sale
get your takes now to evac a comm let it
do hey buddy what's name Chris Cuomo
what you marry him
that's the fun we're out
[Music]
OOP there it is
hoop there is his hoop Thera says who
whoop whoop whoop whoop there it is
hooby on my wrist there's a hoop on my
wrist measuring my heart rate and a lot
of other things want to know how I sleep
whoop whoop is there want to know how I
recover curve cover
whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo biz on my wrist you
can be a really cool a new loop is all
there is to keep being myself completely
healthy I want to track my metrics and
it will will be whoop will be on my
wrist and I don't even know it looks
like a cool little black band oh mmm
OOP it's a whoop on my wrist a whoop on
my wrist a whoopee whoopee whoop what's
that cool little black band on your
wrist it's a poop poop poop on my wrists
but what does it do it tracks my Hori my
heart rate and my sleep and my recovery
whoo-oop makes me go whoo folks make me
go whoo
cuz it keeps me alive for a long time
and it measures all my metrics oh yeah
oh yeah get the whoop strap this is your
heart rate monitor and measures your
heart rate 100 times per second 24/7
videos huh it's rolling videos on you
stupid son of a [ __ ] man you got to get
it together I just sang a whole song
yeah man you could have been like you
could have been giving me a beat Oh what
you know full day heart rate monitoring
with insights in the heart rate average
heart rate all kinds of different kinds
of you know things on heart rates just
see what your strain is see no one does
it better perform hovering strain it
takes your heart rate 24/7 hundred times
per season
where are you know all the time where is
it I am dude I have to take it off
during that last interview but I have it
on all the damn time but - so how many
calories I'm burning I know exactly what
I need to do to get this body right go
to just just go to whoop calm that's wh
Oh Oh Pete calm use promo code fighter
at checkout to save
thirty dollars and optimized the way you
train it's the only way woot measures
your strained like when you work out
your recovery and we collars you're
burning your heart rate a five-day
battery life they have everything man go
to whoop calm promo code is fighter
that's whoop calm promo code fighter